what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have quite a bit of news
going on in the Marvel Universe and a
slight bit of DC news as well for the DC
fans out there today we'll be talking
about Spider-Man 4 and some updates
about its possible new release date
we'll be talking about the world war
Hulk Solo movie and the ending of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. don't
worry no big spoilers here but James
Gunn did recently come out and kind of
talk about how it's going to end and it
does sound super super emotional and you
just kind of feel like a lot of the
Guardians are gonna die and then we also
have some updates about ccxb Marvel
Studios is attending ccxp and if you
caught my video yesterday you know that
it said Marvel Studios has some
surprises for us coming at ccxp possibly
a new trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania may be something for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 or maybe
something for secret Invasion as those
are the next projects coming up for
Marvel Studio I would not expect
anything about Spider-Man 4 to be
announced because Sony has pulled out of
ccxb and if there was any type of
announcement that was going to be coming
it would be from Sony not Marvel Studios
Sony always handles the announcements
although today it does seem like we have
found out why Sony has decided to skip
ccxb this year it looks like Sony could
be changing some things in their
spider-verse and the movies that they
have coming up for the spider-verse it's
been reported that Sony Pictures has
officially informed ccxp that they will
not participate this year as its main
titles had a date change which prevented
large actions from being viable for this
edition of the event so some of their
main titles are having date changes and
according to Alex P from the cosmic
circus who has been providing updates
about ccxb and Sony not attending Alex
tweeted the more likely candidate for a
date shift would be Spider-Man 4
probably to December 2024 but given how
that project is still two years away the
date shift probably refers to one of the
2023 films coming up so either Madame
Webb Craven the hunter or across the
spider-verse now anytime Sony kind of
shifts something it makes you feel a
little bit uneasy Sony has been kind of
rough lately with what they exactly want
to do with their spider-verse it seems
like their plan is constantly changing
which is fine if you are changing for
the better and recently it does seem
like Sony does have a better plan rumor
has it that they are working up for a
huge spider-verse film where a ton of
different Spider-Man variants come
together in one Universe an event in the
comics titled spider gettin so hopefully
whatever date changes are being made are
for good reasons and I want to say and
this is just speculation on my part that
they are making these changes to include
more of Tom Holland Spider-Man in the
Sony spider-verse we already know that
there is going to be a baby Peter Parker
in Madame Webb Madam Webb is supposed to
explore multiple universes as well so it
could be a Peter Parker of Another
Universe and it's even rumored that
there is going to be a Peter Parker in
the main universe that Madam Webb exists
in that is not Tom Holland's Peter
Parker which does make sense because it
is a completely different Universe
however we have recently heard that Tom
Holland Spider-Man is going to be in
across the spider-verse the new
Spider-Man animated movie so clearly
Sony has plans for all of their
universes to interact with each other so
it would make sense that Tom Holland
Spider-Man would come over as well so if
there is a date shift for Spider-Man 4
hopefully it's because they are trying
to work Tom Holland's Spider-Man in
another spider-verse movie I do think
this would be a good move by Sony and
Sony has been working really closely
with Kevin feige recently so I think
they could pull this off we'll have to
wait and see on this but let me know
your thoughts about it in the comments
down below now like I said the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 ending based off of
everything that we've heard seems like
it's going to be pretty sad so get your
tissues ready we'll talk about that in
just a bit but first thank you to Mint
mobile for sponsoring this video most
people know about mint mobile because of
Ryan Reynolds but most people don't know
about mint Mobile's amazing quality now
I live in the mountains and service
isn't too good however mint mobile sent
me a free plan and I get better service
with their plan than I do with my other
provider but what's crazy is their plan
is so much cheaper mint mobile offers
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month they
give you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or a family and at mint
mobile families start at only two lines
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network plus
mint Mobile's Modern Family Plan lets
you mix and match data plan so everyone
gets the amount of data that's right for
them and you can use your own phone and
keep your same number and contacts so to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month including the Modern
Family Plan go to mintmobile.com Cosmic
that's mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your
wireless bill down to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
Cosmic so as I mentioned James Gunn has
recently spoken to comicbook.com about
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. and he
said it was really hard he said making
the much bigger Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 which will bring back 2014 Gamora
post Avengers endgame and introduces
Cosmic characters like the high
evolutionary and Adam Warlock was really
hard for James Gunn he said especially
after becoming co-chair of DC Studios so
right off the bat if you are worried
about Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 not
being so good because let's face it most
trilogies the third movie is typically
the worst one well don't worry so much
because James Gunn is totally aware of
this here's what he had to say about the
finale of the trilogy he said I think I
felt a lot of pressure before because it
really matters to me that we end the
story well I'll be honest I started
looking at all the trilogies that have
existed throughout time and in most
trilogies the third movie is awful
there's a couple of exceptions but when
I say a couple I mean like two or three
it's very very rare that the third movie
in a franchise is good so it was
important to me that we really ended
this story in a good way the article
goes on to say along with a tear-jerker
origin story for baby rocket a lot of
volume 3 is going back to see the
beginning so that we can really see the
end we see the importance of Rocket's
character and who he is it was just
important to me that it worked and that
I did everything possible I could for
the sake of these characters and for the
fans so I put my all into it so we know
because Marvel Studios announced it that
shakuria wooji is going to be playing
the high evolutionary in Guardians 3. we
know that the high evolutionary made
Rocket Raccoon the high evolutionary is
known for experimenting on animals and
making them become essentially human or
at least having the intelligence of
humans but remaining Animals still much
like Rocket Raccoon we even heard
Brockett in the Guardians movie talk
about how he didn't ask to be made he
didn't ask to be turned into a monster
well in this third guardians of the
Galaxy film we're going to explore that
now a lot of people are really worried
that Rocket Raccoon is going to die and
that a lot of the Guardians are going to
die a lot of the Guardians cast said
that when they read the script and they
read the ending they were filled with
tears and James Gunn has said in another
interview with comicbook.com that we
know most of them are going to make it
out alive implying that there are going
to be some that are going to die and
since James Gunn has expressed that he
pretty much believes that this is going
to be his final Marvel project he said
Never Say Never but he does believe this
will be his final one he's gonna close
out the story the way he feels it needs
to be closed out and that could be some
deaths but there is some hope because in
this interview with comicbook.com he
does say this is the end of that story
referring to Guardians volume 3 I'm
sorry some stories have an end but it
doesn't mean everybody dies and hey
fingers crossed that we don't lose
anybody but we do know that moving
forward after Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 there will be a new Guardians team
hopefully Star-Lord remain remains a
part of it and hopefully Adam Warlock
joins as well but for the rest of them
we'll have to wait and see also James
Gunn has expressed that he will not be
attending ccxb this year for Marvel or
DC as he is finishing the DC slate and
he is expressed and DC has expressed
that they are planning to get together
to talk about the entirety of the slate
and reveal it on January of this year so
for the DC fans get ready because I
think James Gunn is going to completely
turn around DC and make it really great
again and yes we will be talking a lot
more about DC and last but not least it
looks like the rights for the Hulk and a
solo film for the Hulk are coming back
to Marvel Studios in apparently two
years today in a tweet the MCU direct
tweeted Hulk's theatrical rights are
reportedly still owned by Universal
Studios but The Insider account my time
to shine hello who has been very
accurate about a lot of things with the
MCU as special leaks says for now
they'll get the rights back in the next
two years which means that we are not
getting a Hulk so solo film within the
next two years even though it was teased
in She-Hulk especially with the
introduction of and spoiler alert if you
have not seen the She-Hulk finale scar
Hulk's son now the Hulk Solo movie has
been rumored to be a World War Hulk solo
film and She-Hulk made it very clear
that there is going to be a Hulk movie
however they don't exactly tell us when
it's going to take place it could be a
recap of the events that took place on
sakhar and could be set back in time I
hope they don't do this but it very well
could happen this way the other option
of course is it happens after two years
and they keep it in the timeline but
that would probably mean it would come
after Avengers Secret Wars which could
be good or it could be bad I for one
want a full on Hulk for Avengers Secret
Wars I want to see the Hulk Hulk out
again in his full rage I don't want to
see a professor Hulk so hopefully we
don't have to wait for the Hulk movie to
see that actually happen or if we do
hopefully that movie comes out before
Secret Wars but Avengers Secret Wars
comes out November 7th of 2025 Which is
less than two years away maybe they can
work out something in between but as of
right now A Hope Solo film is going to
be coming after Avengers Secret Wars
that doesn't mean we won't see Hulk and
other projects and see him Hulk out but
for his solo film it looks like it's
probably coming in 2026 but hey let me
know what you think about all of this
news in the comments down below and let
me know if you think one of the
Guardians of the Galaxy is going to die
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest news for live updates you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign